für den verdacht reicht es aus wenn
tatsachen belegen dass mit einer
gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit eine
bestimmte straftat begangen wurde
[Musik]
grund waren sie nur falls ich habe geld
geholt
[Musik]
woher haben sie diese kunstgegenstände
ich habe sie von meinem vater hat sie
zum größten teil gekauft
handeln sie mit kunst das habe ich nie
was machen sie damit all diesen bildern
hier nicht bloß auf sie auf
[Musik]
sie waren versteckt in einer kleinen
wohnung in münchen
und sind jetzt auf den weg in die
schweiz die bilder des cornelius cornet
dieser transport war der vorläufige
höhepunkt einer spektakulären geschichte
[Musik]
lange musste das kunstmuseum bern auf
diese heikle fracht warten denn es liegt
ein schatten über diesen kunstwerken
während der nationalsozialisten als
entartet deklarierte und aus den museen
verband waren sie jahrzehntelang
verschulden jetzt kamen sie in bern das
erste mal ans licht ich kann aber dankte
es ist ob sie wollen 10 also einerseits
historische chance für für edv und
kunsthistoriker wo sich mit der thematik
befasst hat jetzt wirklich einmal sich
mit so einer riesigen konvolut uns
beschäftigen will zusammengeschnitten
zweiten mal kreativ aber ist dieser
problematischen sich das ist mir von
anfang an klar xxi
[Musik]
die entdeckung der sammlung gurlitt
begann in lindau am bodensee im jahr
2010 im zollfahndungsamt landete der
bericht zweier zöllner
sie hatten einen alten mann im zug von
zürich nach münchen kontrolliert eine
kontrolle die jede andere
doch es gab unterschiede anhand des
aktenvermerks der sr vorliegt lässt sich
rekonstruieren was geschehen war
weiter vollgas gott die ausweise bitte
deutschland sollte es gut vielen dank
woher kommen sie aus zürich
aus zürich zeigt man ihre fahrkarte
bitte
sie sehen heute morgen von münchen nach
zürich gereist haben sie größere mengen
bargeld dabei eröffne sie bitte den
aktenkoffer
ich würde heute morgen schon
kontrolliert haben sie bargeld auf sich
muss man sich eben nicht sagen
unrichtige angaben stelle eine
ordnungswidrigkeit dar und können den
verdacht einer geldwäsche handel
begründen denn das klar
stehen sie bitte auf
kommen sie bitte mit dafür können sie
mitnehmen
[Musik]
den spd mann klaus
woher stammt dieses geld muss ich nicht
sagen
1000 mal 1000 euro mit zu führen ist ja
erlaubt
warum haben sie nichts davon gesagt
ein konto in der schweiz nein ich habe
kein konto in der schweiz wo er stand an
dieses geld
diese keinen grund ihnen die herkunft
des geldes preiszugeben der
anlagevermögen im ausland haben sie eine
mitwirkungspflicht
das kostest aus der schweiz
aus dem verkauf von bildern mein vater
während der ns zeit an einen schweizer
auktionshaus verkauft hat mein vater war
damals museumsleiter in zwickau
hildebrandt gurlitt der vater von
cornelius er war einer der vier
wichtigsten kunsthändler die während des
nazi-regimes mit entarteter kunst
handelt die großmutter von hildebrand
war zwar jüdin
trotzdem verkaufte hildebrand kunst die
von den nazis aus ihren eigenen museen
verbannt worden war ins ausland als er
dann im besetzten frankreich zum
einkäufer bode für das von hitler
geplante führermuseum hatte er sich mit
den nazis längst arrangiert
er profitierte vom regime und rettete
gleichzeitig die kunst vor der
vernichtung der autor und filmemacher
maurice philip remy hat über das
schicksal der görlitz ein buch
geschrieben
für ihn ist klar der name gurlitt ließ
bei den zollfahndern alle alarmglocken
läuten
der zöllner der ihn untersucht hat der
schreib drei tage später am sonntag in
friedrichshafen glaube ich sitzt er an
seinem computer und schreibt das
protokoll das macht der standardmäßig
der schreibt wahrscheinlich 20
protokolle über 20 solche begegnungen
und da schreibt er also rein der hat
hier gesagt das geld was er da bringt
das hat sein vater und so wie heißt der
gurlitt dann geht er zu google gibt den
namen geriet ein ding da stets dann
handelte mit raubkunst im dritten reich
wenn cornelius gold diesen einen satz
nicht gesagt hätte er nie etwas passiert
die vergangenheit seines vaters und die
9000 euro im zug reichten aus um einen
handel mit geraubter kunst zu vermuten
die fahnder verdächtigten cornelius
kolig illegal bilder in die schweiz zu
bringen und dabei steuern zu
hinterziehen
sie alarmierten die staatsanwaltschaft
in augsburg
die ohne zögern ein ermittlungsverfahren
gegen goliath einleitete bei dieser
verdachtsunabhängigen kontrolle haben
sich keine anhaltspunkte für einen
bestimmten tatverdacht gegeben aber es
gab auffälligkeiten diese
auffälligkeiten haben die zollbehörden
bewogen weitere vorermittlungen zu
tätigen die dann in der zusammenschau
insgesamt zu einem tatverdacht wegen des
verdachts der steuerhinterziehung
geführt haben
die fahnder begannen cornelius kolig zu
überwachen
sie installierten kameras vor seinem
wohnhaus in münchen schwabing ein alter
mann mit dieser vergangenheit wovon
lebte dieser mann der nirgends in
deutschland registriert waren
doch gold pferd bloß zum promenadeplatz
auf die bank wo da kaufte sich im nahe
gelegenen kaufhaus unzählige hampton im
sonderangebot
[Musik]
ein jahr nach der kontrolle im zug
meldete sich cornelius kolig beim
auktionshaus lempertz er wollte ein bild
verkaufen
der erste kontakt war tatsächlich ein
telefonanruf von herrn gerrit indem er
fragte ob wir uns für fähig halten ein
gute kunst zu versteigern hätte ein bild
von beckmann anzubieten und ein paar
tage später ergab mit der kutsche platz
adresse
und dann bin ich natürlich hin gefahren
dort traf ich ihn dann
ich war außen geklingelt es wurde
geöffnet in den vierten stock in diesem
quadratischen treppenhaus und dort in
der ecke wo die wohnungstür ist wartete
herr görlitz der sehr freundlich war
aber auch ein bisschen mit abstand
ich habe mühe mich erst mal so ein
bisschen optisch zurechtzufinden und da
hing das bild über dem sofa ein schönes
bild ich muss sie das jetzt fragen
gehört ihnen das bild das bild gehörte
meiner mutter und jetzt gehört es mir
wirklich ein sehr schönes bild
können sie mir eine schätzung machen
gerne
250 300.000 können sie das untere limit
auf 280.000 setzen das kann nicht gern
versuchen jetzt auf den tisch gelegt ich
habe es mir angeschaut ich habe es
umgedreht da sich einige klebezettel
darunter auch die reste des flechtheim
aufklebers bei flechtheim klingeln immer
alle glocken in deutschland das ist
einfach weil es eine unselige geschichte
war mit diesem galeristen dem nicht gut
mitgespielt wurde aber diese fein fragen
wollte ich nicht vor ort mit ihm klären
mir ging es erstmal darum dass ich das
bild bekomme dass er das vertrauen hat
dass wir sowas versteigern können
haben sie noch mehr solcher bilder
na ja sagt er ganz schlicht nein
erklärte nichts er sagte einfach nur
nein das habe ich dann auch zufrieden
gegeben dass beckmann bild kam zur
option und wurde für 870.000 euro
versteigert doch das etikett des
jüdischen galeristen flechtheim auf der
rückseite weckte das interesse der erben
die das bild beanspruchten das
auktionshaus und görlitz wollten
aufmerksamkeit vermeiden
sie einigten sich mit den erben und
teilten den erlös trotz observation den
zollfahndern entgegen der verkauf des mc
bandidos
[Musik]
was ging vor in görlitz verschlossener
welt
[Musik]
da wurden wir sind von der verhandlungen
wir haben durchsuchungsbeschluss
verdacht auf steuerhinterziehung
sie haben das recht auf einen anderen
brauche keinen anwalt
wir sind sie können auch nicht sehr sie
sich bitte da hinten hin und behalten
sie sich ruhig
ich bin dort noch im schlaf gleitmittel
setzten sich kommen sie hätte herr
goalie
bitte setzen sie
sehr gute prise ist raus
herr goalie den schlüssel dazu die soko
mode wurde schon seit jahren nicht mehr
geöffnet
dann muss ich sie aufbrechen wenn sie
wollen
jetzt soll das rad kommen sie mal schaun
sie ist das denn
marc macke el kirchner
unglaublich
wir brauchen experten
[Musik]
die zollfahnder fanden in einem kleinen
zimmer 1200 kunstwerke und waren völlig
überfordert
ohne zu wissen was für bilder sie genau
gefunden hatten hielten sie alles
akribisch fest während drei tagen
blieben sie in der wohnung und packten
alle sein geld akten briefe dokumente
obwohl der verdacht der
steuerhinterziehung ist kaum
rechtfertigte nehmen sie alles mit
[Musik]
bestehen sie nehmen fünf mit die fünf
entscheidenden und stellen fest wo hoch
brisant hochbrisant welche von den 1280
tage lassen sind genauso relevant muss
man dann zum zweiten mal hingehen da
spielt es letztendlich keine rolle wie
viele in diesem fall zum beispiel
kunstwerke es sind wenn man hier von
einer relevanz ausgeht
woher haben sie diese kunstgegenstände
ich habe sie von meinem vater hat sie
zum größten teil gekauft aber viele
waren auch schon länger in
familienbesitz
bei ihrem vater man hat da war ja früher
museumschef bis ihm gekündigt wurde dann
drei kunsthändler notgedrungen stimmt es
dass ihr vater ein viertel jude war ja
nur eine großmutter war jude
und trotzdem hat er für die nazis mit
kunst gehandelt nur so konnte erarbeiten
herr goalie handeln sie mit kunst nein
was machen sie dann mit all diesen
bildern hier nicht ich passe bloß auf
sie auffuhr und leben sie von
kapitaleinkünften aber das ist nicht
viel
also handeln sie mit kunstgegenständen
nein das habe ich nie hilft uns mal ein
bild privat verkauft er nimmt geld habe
ich dann gelebt was arbeiten sie hält
brauche nicht viel geld ich lebe mit
frei haben sie noch nie etwas gearbeitet
doch früher kurz als restaurator aus
welchem grund waren sie in der schweiz
ich habe geld in der schweiz geholt und
meine bestände hier in deutschland nicht
zu sehr zu zu schrumpfen
aber nach dieser kontrolle im zug habe
ich mich nicht mehr getraut in die
schweiz zu fahren
wie kam das geld überhaupt in die
schweiz
ich habe etwas bei einem berner
auktionshaus verkauft er war mehrere
kunstgegenstände die firma ist
international bekannt
wie heißt diese firma galerie kornfeld
mein vater hat früher schon
mit dem geschäfte gemacht sie pflegen
die kontakte ihres vaters aber sie
handeln nicht mit den bildern ihres
vaters nein gut haben sie sonst noch
irgend etwas hinzuzufügen
ja ich möchte dagegen protestieren dass
sie heute hier durchsuchen
ich handle nicht mit bildern und
übrigens warum können sie mit dem ganz
nicht warten bis ich tot bin
cornelius görlitz gesamte kunstsammlung
wurde in ein kunstdepot am rande von
münchen gebracht
unter strengster geheimhaltung
untersuchte die kunsthistorikerin meike
hoffmann die sammlung dort zum ersten
mal
es war einmal eine sammlung da und eben
eine sehr umfangreiche sammlung die
wirklich eine direkte verbindung zum
dritten reich herstellt das war
skandalös beziehungsweise war das auch
aufregend oder es war auch etwas
handgreiflich es sicherlich und dann
eben halt tatsächlich das so eine große
umfangreiche sammlung anscheinend über
70 jahre geheim gehalten werden konnte
schnell wurde klar die bilder gehörten
zum rest bestand eines nazi
kunsthändlers doch die sammlung gehörte
gurlitt wie damit umgehen war alles
raubkunst und musste den erben
bestohlener juden zurückgegeben werden
oder bestand die sammlung vor allem aus
entarteter kunst die hitler aus den
museen verbannt hatte
meike hoffmann suchte antwort auf diese
fragen
die staatsanwaltschaft augsburg hat
nicht dann nachdem ich die sammlung wird
ein erstes mal in augenschein genommen
habe und der staatsanwaltschaft auch
ergebnisse vorgelegt habe mich damit
beauftragt ein gutachten zu verfassen um
eben halt den behörden einen überblick
zu verschaffen was ist denn dort in der
sammlung eventuell verhalten enthalten
und wie muss man damit umgehen während
die bilder in geheimen erforscht wurden
dafür das nachrichtenmagazin focus von
der beschlagnahme noch wussten die
journalisten nicht viel
der erste hinweis war glaube ich sehr
vage wir hatten zwar gehört dass in
einer münchner wohnung bilder
beschlagnahmt worden sind aber wir
wussten schlicht und ergreifend nicht
bei wem und den namen die identität
dieses mannes herauszufinden das hat uns
sehr viel zeit gekostet
warum wurde das so lange geheim gehalten
also da war ich tatsächlich auch ich
habe immer wieder auch der
staatsanwaltschaft gesagt wir müssen
irgendwie an die öffentlichkeit gehen
also die behörden haben natürlich
informationen ihre informationen
bekommen die fühlten sich aber auch
dadurch dass es sich um eine
privatsammlung handelt fühlten sie sich
auch gehindert irgendwie wirklich aktiv
zu werden und so bewegte sich das
mindestens einem jahr immer ziemlich
zähen und her wir waren um ehrlich zu
sein waren wir über tage oder besser
gesagt über mehrere nächte dort haben
vor dem haus nächte verbracht wir waren
dann auch vor der wohnungstür und haben
versucht mit ihm zu sprechen ich meine
mich daran zu erinnern dass wir hinter
der tür auch glaubten geräusche zu hören
da haben wir etliche male nachrichten
hinterlassen aber
er hat sich entschieden nicht zu
antworten das nachrichtenmagazin focus
publizierte die geschichte und löste
damit einen weltweiten aufschrei aus
die staatsanwaltschaft hatte alles
geheim gehalten
jetzt wo alles ans licht kam mussten sie
eiligst stellung beziehen
was genau hatten die zollfahnder in der
wohnung von cornelius kolig gefunden und
wieso das lange stillschweigend der
behörden
wir werden zu gegebener zeit weil wir
auch kunsthistorisch nicht ganz
unbedarft sind natürlich an die
öffentlichkeit gegangen aber dann wenn
es für unsere ermittlungen gepasst hätte
da wurde aufgrund eines verdachts auf
steuerhinterziehung eine gesamte kunst
sammlung beschlagnahmt
doch darum ging es zu diesem zeitpunkt
nicht mehr
der verdacht lag jetzt auf dem besitz
von raubkunst
doch der war nicht straff markt das
ermittlungsverfahren gegen cornelius
college dann plötzlich auf schwachen
rein das ist eine ein urteil ist für
heute tatsächlich so fällen können dass
die beschlagnahme eigentlich nicht
sachgemäß war und eigentlich nicht
gerechtfertigt man muss aber
berücksichtigen dass der fall einmalig
war es gehen
zollbeamte und eine staatsanwaltschaft
geht in eine wohnung in münchen und
findet 70 jahre nach kriegsende einen
unfassbaren einen unfassbaren schatz der
verdacht lag nahe dass es sich um bilder
handelt die alle komplett sozusagen in
irgendeiner form illegal dort liegen und
man hoffte natürlich zunächst einmal
dass man diese bilder in irgendeiner
form retten könnte
die justiz in bayern kam in bedrängnis
hätte man diese sammlung beschlagnahmen
dürfen wem gehören die bilder
tatsächlich die spitzenbeamtin ingeborg
berggreen merkel sollte im auftrag des
bundesministeriums für kultur und medien
lösungen finden
es war klar dass wir handeln mussten und
dass man voran gehen musste um die sache
zu klären
sicher es war der bestand eines privaten
und wenn ein privater nach deutschem
recht etwas im besitz zeit liegt die
vermutung ist es sein eigentum
gleichwohl es war notwendig und es war
gut dass der staat sich darum kümmerte
der freistaat bayern und die
bundesrepublik deutschland zusammen hier
herauszukriegen ist hier unrecht
geschehen wem es unrecht geschehen sind
diese bilder geraubt worden ja oder nein
das war die frage der druck stieg
die eingesetzte task-force sollte
ergebnisse liefern die ganze welt
glaubte man schaut einfach jeden punkt
auf das bild raubkunst alle waren wohl
der meinung ist hier sehr schnell und
man finde sehr viel
die ernüchterung die dann eintrat als
das nicht der fall war hat mich selber
auch getroffen
ich hätte auch ganz gerne erfolgen in
diesem sinne gehabt und jeden tag gelegt
wir haben was gefunden
aber dem war nicht so irgendwann muss
bei der staatsanwaltschaft der gedanke
auch immer klarer geburt geworden sein
dass man normal da nicht mal aus der
sache rauskommt und dass man versuchen
muss mit cholet eine art handel
einzugehen und ihn zu bewegen die bilder
freiwillig abzugeben und ihm
vorzuschlagen dass man sozusagen im
gegenzug die ermittlungen dann fallen
in der zwickmühle der moralischen
verantwortung gegenüber der deutschen
geschichte und einem
ermittlungsverfahren das nicht
standhielt versuchten die behörden mit
cornelius kohle zu verhandeln
ich werde versuchen mit herrn wurde zu
sprechen sobald es geht und brauche in
die spricht partner im gespräch
ich habe versucht ihn zu erreichen habe
ich habe ihn noch nicht erreicht
über wochen belagerten journalisten das
wohnhaus in münchen
und was machte görlitz
[Musik]
bislang nehmen
der winter bekannt geworden davon
scheint nazi raubkunst zu sein
derjenige der eine verheimlichte
geschichte veröffentlicht und damit
enthüllt hat natürlich automatisch auch
die person um die es geht die
mittelpunkt steht an die öffentlichkeit
und das haben wir getan
der verantwortung müssen wir uns auch
stellen und vorbei der wir aber immer
gesagt haben und auch heute noch sagen
das ist richtig so selbst wenn er
sozusagen werden sich seine
lebenssituation durch die
veröffentlichung verschlechtert ist die
veröffentlichung für uns gerechtfertigt
[Musik]
görlitz hatte sich in seiner wohnung
verschanzt
die behörden gingen ein zweites mal rein
sie fanden ihn am ende seiner kräfte und
holten ihn aus
ein münchner gericht stellte ihn unter
betreuung
ich glaube dass diese ganz ungewöhnliche
jagd auf ihn dieses in verfolgen sein
haus belagern dauer klingeln er schreibt
jan seine notizen am rhein klingel
terror klingel tumult ich glaube das hat
ihn aus der bahn geworfen
das war ein schwer kranker mann das hat
ihnen glaube ich den rest gegeben
ich glaube dass der sich in den letzten
wochen des november zurückzog dass er
seine tür nicht mehr auf machte nicht
mehr rausging
und so hat ihn ja dann die polizei auch
gefunden als sie erneut die wohnung
geöffnet hat ich glaube dass der sich
aufgegeben hatte ich glaube dass er
kapituliert hat von dem was auf ihn
zukam
ich glaube er wäre gestorben
in der wohnung vor seinem 81 geburtstag
wenn man ihnen nicht rausgeholt
ich muss jetzt nach hause ich muss ich
muss jetzt nach hause ich gebe sie nicht
mehr her
ich muss mir die bilder denn ideen sagen
muss die bild mein vater hat es auch
gemacht ich kann sie nicht sie mal nach
was sie wollen die märz ist
inmitten eines politischen debakels
musste sich gar mit einer herzoperation
unterziehen
doch die behörden ließen nicht locker
was wenn er sterben würde
ich habe ihm gesagt ich habe ihn
gefunden
ich habe mit ihm gesprochen und es war
eine sehr gute unterhaltung ich habe ihm
klar gelegt wie die situation ist und
habe ihm vorschläge gemacht was er am
besten tun könnte habe ihnen unter
anderem auch vorgeschlagen eine stiftung
zu gründen die sich dem washingtoner
prinzipien unterwirft wo er dann die
bilder sehen kann und ihnen nahe sein
kann und andere möglichkeiten auch und
darüber sollte ja nachdenken als sehr
interessiert zugehört wir haben uns gut
ausgetauscht
[Musik]
guten tag herr gerrit sind sie ich bin
hier not a sie haben mich bestellt mein
name stimmt für den sieger ähnlich
vergoldet sie möchten ein testament
aufsetzen
rechtlich steht eine bypass operation
bevor und die für ein testament machen
solange ich noch in der lage bin
was wollen sie in ihrem testament den
geregelt haben
ich möchte mein gesamtes vermögen einer
stiftung für meine stiftung an welche
stiftung haben sie denn gedacht
im museum in der schweiz
du musst mir zunächst die
rechtsfähigkeit des museums abklären
können sie das tun noch heute alt ist
denn so ja sollte schnell gehen
erkundet haben sie familie
ich hatte eine schwester benita die ist
vor zwei jahren gestorben
gibt diese andere person die sie
begünstigen möchten ein welches museum
wollen sie denn als ihren alleinerben
einsetzen
das kunstmuseum bern haben sie einen
besonderen bezug zu dem kunstmuseum bern
also das muss ich noch nicht sagen wie
groß ist denn ihr vermögen
ich habe zwei eigentumswohnung in
münchen und ein haus in salzburg
ein größeres geldvermögen der deutschen
bank wird der bilder kann ich ihnen noch
nicht nennen
kommt darauf an welche von ihm übrig
bleiben
als matthias frehner vom kunstmuseum
bern das erste mal vom erbe goalie ty
hörte dass er an einem symposium für
raubkunst und diskutierte mit fachleuten
dann klingelte sein telefon was er zu
hören bekam konnte er kaum glauben
[Musik]
drinnen du musst sofort trug osm bayern
hat sony gurlitt gerd und exakt das ist
ein fake news dass stehen klingen und
vorne nicht alle seiner ein scherz
mittels bitte stört mich nicht mit
heutiger labbadia ich bin ziemlich
sicher und anstelle von definitiv
abgestellt und die dritte gegangen
[Musik]
gefallen hat dann der bald edel auch
güte und der heckseite aus wir haben die
summe geld geerbt sie sind alleinerbe
und das ist für mich jetzt eigentlich
nachricht wohn ich nie erwartet hätte
die frau die frage gestellt wo ich noch
hält die duh signal solle beantworteten
ruhms kunstmuseum bayern ja das kann ich
ihnen nicht sagen aber ich kann ihnen
bestätigen dass das stinkt und dann hat
er mir des thomas pdf zurückgestellt
[Musik]
cornelius kolig starb am 6 mai 2014
drei monate nach seiner herzoperation
bei seinem begräbnis waren ein paar
entfernte verwandte dabei aber vor allem
anwälte und beamte und matthias renner
das hat keine wirkliche rolle von
familien okidoki dekoriert vollkommen
gefehlt so zusammen ich sehe das als
möglichen einsamer mann zusammen
[Musik]
das kunstmuseum bern musste sich nun mit
einer belasteten sammlung befassen
matthias trainer sah sich die bilder das
erste mal in einem kunstdepot in münchen
an
sie waren noch im selben zustand wie man
sie bei görlitz gefunden hatte dann hat
ihm einen koffer wie der berg ruft
cornelius kolig das ist ein billiges
oder koffer so groß der mann den hof
gemacht und die dinge sind person
stoppok url zeichnungen und druckgrafik
sie ohne zwischen blätter die da drinnen
oder restauratorin das risiko mit mit
ihrer handschrift ist pleite und ddp
nach b oder die es ist ein alter farbe
einfach total flüchtlings sie mag sie
nicht am werk sind vergleicht einfach
vorstellen frisch also das ist für mich
sensation sie doch nicht alle bilder
waren in einem guten zustand
in görlitz haus in salzburg wo man
monate später noch mehr hochkarätige
bilder fand hatte feuchtigkeit die
bilder angegriffen
oder hat jemand kaufen saison
abgespannt ohne das schwarze bin darüber
großartiger montani saint victor
landschaft also das alles waren sie ins
bild dass es wirkliche sensation
aber so einen schlechten zustand so
schwarz juli zerbe war ein schwieriges
geschenk nicht nur wegen des zustands
der werke welche bilder konnte bern
behalten
ich bin insofern skeptisch als ich
natürlich problematik kanton gestern wie
schwierig das ist es werk jetzt von
raubkunst verdacht befreien
aber da muss man davon abgeleitet sich
folger war es kommt das kunstmuseum
bayern über
die verantwortlichen des kunstmuseums
brauchten bedenkzeit
sie befürchteten klagen und
rückforderungen wegen raubkunst verdacht
die deutsche regierung wollte ein
weiteres debakel im fall gurlitt
verhindern damit sie das erbe annehmen
bodman bern an die verantwortung für den
belasteten teil der sammlung görlitz
übernehmen wir haben unser angebot
sofort gemacht nämlich für den
schwierigeren teil für die raubkunst
fühlt sich die bundesrepublik
organisatorisch finanziell aber vor
allen dingen moralisch verantwortlich
und leistet alle hilfe denn das ist
keine schweizer und schon keine berner
angelegenheit die nazi geschichte
hildebrandt gullit cornelius kolig
raubkunst auch entartete kunst ist eine
deutsche geschichte und so sie sich
verantwortlich fühlen und auch in der
lage sehen dieses erbe zu verwalten
sollen sie sich dafür entscheiden da wo
sie schwierigkeiten haben mit mit mit
dem zugeständnis hilft die
bundesrepublik deutschland eine sammlung
an zwei orten
das kunstmuseum bern würde nur die
bilder nehmen die historisch einwandfrei
waren die schweizer wollten das erbe
aber ohne die schatten der vergangenheit
der stiftungsrat des kunstmuseums bären
hat in seiner sitzung vom 22
november 2014 geschlossen den ihm von
cornelius kolig testamentarisch
vermachten nachweis anzutreten
die vereinbarung zwischen deutschland
bayern und bern sah vor dass alle bilder
die nicht restlos vom verdacht der
raubkunst befreit wären in deutschland
bleiben
[Musik]
drei jahre nach dieser vereinbarung
lagern viele bilder noch tief unten im
depot der bundeskunsthalle in bonn
es gibt lücken in der herkunft der
bilder der verdacht auf haupt kunst
konnte nicht ausgeräumt werden erst fünf
bilder sind an erben zurückgegeben
worden bei der waterloo bridge von monet
weiß man bis heute nicht wie sie in die
sammlung gurlitt gekommen war
natürlich hoffen wir mit der ausstellung
weiterzukommen natürlich hoffen wir dass
irgendwann mal jemand aufsteht und sagt
das ist ein werk was mir gehört hat das
war von anfang an auch eine wichtige
absicht der ausstellung ob das
tatsächlich stattfinden wird und ob
tatsächlich kleben sie berechtigt sind
aus der ausstellung herauskommen werden
das muss man natürlich bezweifeln
wenn das passiert hätten wir aber einen
wichtigen zweck mit diesen ausstellung
letztendlich dienen können
was geschieht aber mit bildern deren
provenienz nie ganz aufgeklärt werden
kann wird ein teil der sammlung gurlitt
für immer in deutschland bleiben
[Musik]
bern wird entscheiden müssen bisher
holte es die bilder ins museum die als
entartete kunst galten und damit
unbedenklich sind
es sind vor allem zeichnungen und
grafiken des deutschen expressionismus
sicher ein gewichtiger teil der gesamten
sammlung wollitz
[Musik]
doch das kunstmuseum bern wird in
zukunft bei jedem bild abwägen müssen ob
es an der weißen wand hängen darf oder
nicht
[Musik]
wenn es nur lücken gibt die aber nicht
verdachtsmomente haben die nach gesunden
menschenverstand einfach zu erklären
sind und ansonsten sind die werke
problemlos dann nehmen wir die werke in
unserem besitz und forschen weiter
falls wir uns irgendwo restituieren wir
dann aber alle werke wo ein
anfangsverdacht besteht name die
einschlägig sind lücken in den falschen
orten zur falschen zeit mit den falschen
menschen die beteiligt waren
da porsche weiter bis klar ist wie die
sachlage ist
matthias frehner hat einen weiten weg
hinter sich
zum ersten mal sieht der görlitz bilder
nebeneinander
[Musik]
zusammen gekauft während der zeit der
nazis über jahrzehnte versteckt in einer
wohnung in münchen breitet matthias
frehner diese bilder jetzt aus zu einer
ausstellung in seinem museum
[Musik]
das kunstmuseum bern wird noch lange mit
görlitz vermächtnis zu tun haben
immer wieder muss matthias frehner an
den letzten willen von cornelius kolig
denken
niemand weiß was er wirklich sich über
leid hat villa villa alexis und villa
das aktuelle mitteilen
aber es gibt so viel bestätigen die im
moment wo ich jetzt unterzieht wurde ich
mich mit dem thema beschäftigen vor
wochen dass ich denke jahre hat sich
wirklich präzise über leid dass das
davon gehören das puzzle es passt sehr
viel möglich damen
[Musik]